and what really matters to me is history
and my character
of history uh her history of
where she was and over the river and
through the woods she's been
[Laughter]
judy just told me what happened at the
wedding you saved the day
yeah it wasn't a big deal
right stopping a mad woman from killing
the bride
how mundane let's get right to it
christian talk to me about what
went into your decision about
leaving i almost want to call it your
alma mater your home your family your
your club your you know that's your crew
there for so long
days of our lives 37 years what what
talked to me about that decision to
to leave well i had had a conversation
with ken corday who is our executive
producer
um of days for lives and we're having a
conversation and during the conversation
he told me that ron our head writer
carlotti
and albert allar who is our co-executive
producer
thought that it was best to take me off
canvas for four to five months and
during that time i paused thinking
why it was not something that had ever
been discussed
um but that's what it was and to come
back
in five to six months or four or five
months or whatever that time span
was um i just thought you know what it's
time to
really write a new chapter i've had an
incredible run there
i have so many amazing
friends and memories um
i cannot say enough how
much i'll miss so many people working
there
and working with them but they are in my
life
um and we do socialize and but like i
said
i think it's time um i felt it was
anyway and
so far i really this time during covid
which has been so horrific
for our country for the world it really
made me pause and think um
about life and to really appreciate our
health
every single day and never take it for
granted obviously in some trouble
yeah a little how can i help
i need to make a phone call
well that is um it's so well said
just everything you spoke on there i i
mean
going just back to the grind that is
soap opera existence i i i was on um i
did general hospital for three years at
about 400 episodes and
the amount of material the amount of
story lines
the amount of work paid oh my god
and people would say to me how do you
remember
all of that dialogue and some days some
days some weeks we'd be shooting
eight and a half episodes um which
i honestly don't know how the dialogue
would come out of my mouth
but i have to say you know i talk about
the cast but i have to take my hat off
to our crew
who i love and adore as much as
so many of our cast members um we were
all in it together
we all wanted the best for the show um
and it's all the little details that
count i actually have a question about
that so days correct me if i'm wrong
you guys shoot a head uh you're one of
the few soaps that
shoot enough ahead that i know you guys
have episodes shot
until october and you even though you're
done actually working shooting your
material
you will continue to air how come the
announcement did you decide to
uh you know make the announcement that
you're leaving now opposed to
kind of waiting you know until more of
your episodes ran out you know i felt
that i owed it to the audience
um the viewers who have
watched for so long i didn't want to
hide anything i've always been upfront
very honest sometimes i get in trouble
for being so honest and
well um but i just felt that i really
wanted to
to share what my decision was i didn't
want to be a shock or a surprise
when all of a sudden you know hope
disappears in the attic or she's off
looking for someone
or uh maybe she's taking a trip or she's
i don't know i don't know what they will
come up with i mean i do but i cannot
share that because that would spoil it
um but um
i just i told my husband which you know
i had
i had really thought about leaving um
mulling it over i would say probably for
the last few years
but when this phone call came and you
know during our discussion he told me
you know the news about um that ron and
albert
indeed did want to take me off campus
for those months
it was almost as if he opened that but
want to bring me back
i will say that as well in but who knows
i mean
here today gone tomorrow um but
it was as if ken had opened that door
for me just a little
bit and i opened it all the way
and made the decision and to to depart
the days of our lives
um which you know was my family for
such a long time i don't want to ruin
our happiness
and what about your happiness what about
that what are you going to miss
most now obviously i know you are going
to miss
that family of human beings that you
spent such a great deal of your life
with but
what else what else are you really going
to miss about being on that set and what
are you taking or what have you taken
over the years
as a memento as a souvenir as a
collectible from your
your character and your time there well
you know what will i
take from it well i will take all of the
memories and
um which i'm so lucky to have because
you know many don't will not have that i
mean i'm going to miss the people
that i was so blessed to be able to work
with
um i will not miss my messy dressing
room
um that still needs to be cleaned out
randy i need to call you we need to
arrange that
um i love him he's such a great guy um
he's the unit producer
randy dugan um but i do need to arrange
that
um
i will see them again not on the set of
days of our lives
um because i don't plan on returning um
and popping in
as um others have done in the past
um i think that that
that chapter has closed and a new one
needs to be started it is that's very
well said and you are a hundred percent
right um
prime time does follow in that in the in
those lovely footsteps laid out for them
now
beau and hope's wedding was a a major
moment iconic moment
e.t entertainment tonight was there
when it all went down oh my gosh you
were at the church on highland
we have a little something we want to
show you
i think also one of the reasons they
married us off was because they thought
i was going to be leaving
which i thought i was going to be
leaving also but uh
i'm staying for one more year i have 10
months left it's all true
oh my gosh my voice was so high but your
heart
your heart is the same
your heart your heart your words
everything we've talked about thus far
in this
this interview has been echoed in those
years past you haven't changed
a bit and that's what's so beautiful is
that you have your innocence
you have your heart and you're taking
that with you still intact
which a lot of actors can't say yes i
cannot reiterate or say enough with
enough emphasis
that days of our lives blessed me
incredibly and i take that with me
many memories i learned a lot there were
great moments
also not always perfection
um but pretty damn close
that is incredible what was it like do
you remember
when you got cast when you got offered
however it happened how you got the role
did you have any concept of what an icon
you would become an icon i am a very
lucky i would say girl but this
people would say well you're not a girl
anymore you're a woman but i would say
i'm just a very lucky girl i mean i
truly i mean i worked my
tail off um but i
was very lucky to get the opportunity
did i ever
think that i would be on a show for so
many years
no i didn't i didn't realize that
um no i never took anything for granted
ever
ever ever i love working together with
people
i love working with actors that give
that are prepared that um don't
take it for granted that show up
knowing their dialogue and people that
and our lighting directors like
out there when he doesn't need to be out
there but those all of those
things i pay attention to and what
really matters to me is history
and my character of history uh
her history of where she was and
over the river and through the woods
she's been not over i have not always
agreed with
where her direction um
but you know we've had so many different
writers and so many different producers
but i will say that i am grateful
for all of them because i have learned
something i mean
seriously i have learned so much from
everyone
um and i love them and they will always
have a piece of my heart and i will
always be so grateful
and never take them for granted because
i have learned so much and to work with
such
seriously every morning i would walk out
on set whether it was morning or night
it was always good morning everybody um
because it was my first
um my first scenes on set
and i always felt so welcomed and would
you know hear the echo back good morning
christian morning christian good morning
hey fishy what's going on oh i like that
oh is that what you're gonna bring
tonight
um so
that's what i will miss and they will
never hear me say
good morning everybody let's do a great
show today let's do the best we can
um because i always wanted to do and
give
the best because that's what was
expected and um
i never want to let anyone down and
especially the audience